la tenue de la COP15 à Montréal en
décembre la grande conférence des
Nations Unies a ramené à l'avant-scène
l'enjeu de la perte de biodiversité
c'est un phénomène évidemment mondial
mais qui se mesure aussi à toute petite
échelle près de chez nous voyez
d'ailleurs comment des bénévoles au
bassin Laurent travaillent à un projet
ambitieux faire revivre une partie de la
biodiversité perdue de l'île verte
voici l'histoire improbable du retour
d'un oiseau sur son île
c'est pas une idée là c'est un projet et
on le fait cette histoire démarre en
plein milieu du Saint-Laurent
elle se transporte au confins des chic
choc en Gaspésie on ne la chance de
redonner un certain habitat au tétra
et elle se termine là où tout a commencé
à l'île verte
[Musique]
voici comment le tetran du Canada
pourrait bien revenir sur l'île d'où il
a disparu il faisait partie de la
biodiversité de l'île et pourquoi pas le
remettre
l'île Verte un morceau de verdure de 11
km² dans le Saint-Laurent
[Musique]
malgré sa petite taille
350 personnes vivaient ici au milieu du
siècle dernier
[Musique]
l'île porte encore les traces de sa
colonisation intensive
[Musique]
Gilbert Delage est l'ancien maire de
l'île Verte il dirige un organisme qui
cherche à protéger ce qui reste de
biodiversité sur l'île
des coupes forestières de même qu'une
chasse intensive ont appauvri la
biodiversité sur l'île
la perdrix et le tétra du Canada par
exemple ont disparu
chevreuil il y avait plus de ravages de
chevreuil sur l'île papy ladage disait
que un chevreuil entré sur l'île quelle
que soit la période l'année son
espérance de vie à 24 heures
mais ce territoire retrouve peu à peu
son équilibre naturel
les gens ont quitté l'île de 350 on est
passé à 30 permanent et il y a pas
d'agriculture à peu près pas
d'exploitation forestière alors ça leur
permet à la forêt de regagner ses droits
sur une cinquantaine d'années
l'île redevient accueillante pour la
faune et des citoyens ont même
réintroduit la perdrix avec succès
mais Gilbert Delage veut aller encore
plus loin
il veut ramener le tétra du Canada un
oiseau emblématique des forêts de
conifères
lorsqu'on me dit que il y en avait à
Lille on parlait donc de réintroduction
et moi c'était suffisant pour allumer la
mèche on peut dire ça déjà existé et ça
ne peut pas revenir tout seul parce que
c'est un oiseau qui vole très peu c'est
un oiseau forestier donc c'est pas nos
omégateur il fallait aller le chercher
là où il était et il était loin d'ici
l'habitat semble être de mieux en mieux
aussi 400 km à l'est de l'île Verte la
réserve phonique des chics chocs
nous sommes au cœur des forêts de
conifères de la Gaspésie un habitat
parfait pour le tétra comment ça va
Pascal petitgroux supervise les captures
son université a déjà réintroduit avec
succès le tétra du Canada sur l'île
d'Anticosti
il cherche des femelles accompagnées de
leurs jeunes les tatouages vinyles vont
se nourrir beaucoup d'insectes puis
lorsqu'on a des chemins comme ça dénudés
ça favorise aussi par exemple les nids
de fourmis etc donc les femelles vont se
rapprocher là des chemins pour entre
autres nourrir les jeunes ils ont besoin
d'une cinquantaine de tétra pour assurer
une diversité génétique et garantir le
succès de la réintroduction
[Musique]
on va aller prendre les perches
les captures se font à l'aide d'un
collet monté au bout d'une perche
la technique est éprouvée mais pas
infaillible
il est encore tôt et la caravane se
déplace dans un autre secteur
[Musique]
pour faciliter les captures on mis sur
l'instinct de camouflage du Tetra
quand il se sent menacé il reste
immobile pour échapper à ses prédateurs
Gilbert Delage compte aussi sur l'aile
de Daniel Dussault un habitué de ses
captures au début c'est comme ça que il
faut ramasser les oiseaux on croyait pas
beaucoup en disant qu'on va faire ça
l'oiseau il va bouger il va te faire
mais on réussit quand même
laisser sur sa branche et de l'attraper
c'est une technique éprouvée en fait que
cette capture là nous permet de faire ça
assez rapidement donc on va capturer
l'oiseau ensuite on le maîtrise
rapidement puis on va l'amener dans une
cage de rétention
ça c'est un jeune on voit par la
grosseur mais on voit que la sorcière là
elle est atteinte découpée on a la
famille au complet parce qu'on a pas vu
voler donc du tout puis on entendrait
aussi souvent des petits vont pieuvrier
le secteur est favorable et Pascal
capture rapidement un autre jeune
[Musique]
la femelle a rentré juste sous les
peanuts
mais cette fois-ci sa mère est
introuvable
parce que c'est la femelle qui fait
l'éducation des jeunes et c'est pour
augmenter l'espérance de vie dans le
fond des petits face à la prédation puis
tout ça à leur enseigne comment se
protéger l'équipe veut attraper un
maximum d'oiseaux mais le protocole est
rigoureux il faut chaque fois capturer
la famille au grand complet
malgré tous les efforts la femelle reste
introuvable on avait pris un premier
mais à n'a pas été capable de d'attraper
la femelle alors on a relâché
effectivement le juvénile quand on roule
la cage tout le monde s'en va au vol
puissant puis ils sont en pleine forme
tous les jours à un abri on en a déjà 22
de prix actuellement donc il nous en
reste 18 à attraper au cours de des 9
prochains jours alors ça s'annonce très
bien on sourit déjà
au lendemain des captures l'équipe prend
la route du retour
à la traversée pour l'île Verte de
nouveaux bénévoles prennent le relais
le biologiste est auteur Pierre-Henri
fontaine assure chacune des traversées
de Tetra
résidant de l'île verte c'est un
bénévole de la première heure ça me
tient à cœur parce que je me sens prêt à
soutenir dans mes moyens avec mes moyens
tous les projets de ce genre qui à un
moment donné vont redonner de la vie et
une vie particulière à Lille
au Québec le Tetra est devenu rare un
peu partout dans le sud de son air de
distribution en raison des coupes
forestières
son retour à l'île Verte est une
occasion pour les bénévoles de lui
redonner un peu de ce territoire perdu
attention pour des petits moineaux
sont en grande forme
les remises en liberté se font dans
cette forêt de conifères au centre de
Lille
la chasse y est interdite et des
bénévoles y ont déjà planté du mélèze
pour favoriser la survie des nouveaux
arrivants
jusqu'à maintenant tous les oiseaux ont
très bien résisté au transport c'est
très intéressant
quand il voit ses tétrasses alimentées
Gilbert Delage et chaque fois rassuré
que les oiseaux ont été manipulés avec
soin c'est la pérennité de l'espèce
qu'on veut nous c'est merveilleux
on crée une nouvelle vie ici d'option
plaisir
dans les années 60 je me rappelle d'en
avoir vu mais très peu c'est très
occasionnel et là de savoir qu'on les
remet qu'on reconstitue une population
sur l'île c'est merveilleux les
bénévoles ont jusqu'ici capturés et
relâcher la presque totalité des tétras
d'autres suivront dans les prochains
jours
en ramenant le tétra sur son île Gilbert
Delage fait plus que redonner à l'oiseau
un territoire perdu il a le sentiment de
protéger l'ensemble de la biodiversité
de l'île c'est une espèce proie il y a
toute une chaîne d'oiseaux et d'animaux
qui sont des prédateurs alors en
ajoutant une espèce on ajoute aussi un
renforcement de tous les autres espèces
je dirais pour assurer cette diversifier
là en continu
l'île Verte a vu ses populations
animales déclinées en raison de
l'activité humaine
aujourd'hui c'est toute une communauté
qui se mobilise pour renverser cette
tendance
la plupart des gens voient la nature
comme juste un endroit où on va se
reposer quand on sort de la ville mais
c'est bien plus que ça c'est le poumon
de la terre c'est le c'est ce qui pompe
le CO2 qui nous fournit de l'oxygène et
chaque fois qu'on peut
ramener quelqu'un un animal par exemple
dans son milieu la leur restaurer
l'animal dans son milieu ben il faut le
faire
explosion de bonheur un feu d'artifice
parce que ça partait de trouver et tout
et puis on voyait que c'était tous en
santé et même dans le transport quand je
transportais les oiseaux je savais que
j'avais un trésor en arrière de moi et
quand on les relâche on dit ok ils ont
fini l'intermédiaire maintenant ils sont
dans leur milieu alors ça c'était
toujours extraordinaire à chaque fois
dernière opération dernière cage les
derniers tétras
[Musique]